The best answer is the second one here.
The argument goes like this.
As I stated in the hint,
the longest representation of a number
after i steps is order n plus i.
Addition can lengthen the binary
representation of a number
by at most one bit.
Next, observe that the total number
of symbols used, let's say l,
increases by at most order ri
as the i step is simulated.
We might get this increase by writing
a number to the random access device
to a location that we
haven't written to before.
Thus, after step j,
the total number of symbols used,
is going to be order n + j squared.
Finally, each step only takes a constant
number of passes over the symbols used
on the tape, so
we can bound the total number of steps
with this sum here, to get the result.